all right guys
bang bang i've got eric here with me uh
thanks so much for doing this man
i'm so excited to be here thanks for
having me bang bang
[Laughter]
very few people ever hit me back with
the bang bang that's good they're not
ready for it
uh let's just jump into your background
i know we're gonna spend a bunch of time
talking about the uh the book that you
recently released but
uh for those that don't know who you are
maybe just give us kind of a quick
summary of your background
uh and then what you do as a day job and
kind of did before the book
yeah um i kind of was lucky to grow up
in like a small business house
so it was kind of normal for like
entrepreneur to be a job
um for us like my dad ran a small
business and you know my uncle had a
pizza joint and newspaper and like stuff
was always going around so i was like
the kid selling candy out of my locker
and
uh you know had my first brush with
regulators in like seventh grade
um but we're uh we got into
um startups in college and stuff like
that so that was when facebook was
really big
and started learning more and more about
the tech world and have been in startups
for the last kind of 10 years or so
um actually like half dropped out and
then ended up getting a degree um
but in the process like joins harley and
so i've been there for
10 years um ups and downs and back and
forth and a couple pivots and different
business models
and we're now kind of building a
marketplace
for home services like a managed
marketplace vertically integrates kind
of all the way through but a true
marketplace
um rather than just a directory or lead
gen site so
that's kind of the day job i do product
strategy there
but i've always been like learning kind
of sharing writing in public
um doing the best i can to kind of share
my lessons learned along the way and i
have done um it was a blog called
evergreen kind of back in 2015 16 was
the start of that
and that was another kind of curation in
a different medium
um and that got got quite popular and
then um
as that i kind of wasn't sure what to
take the next step on with that
like this project just came up and so
this has been the last like three years
for me
so uh it's really interesting because i
think that uh
you've got a job every day that you go
to work and uh
you think about technology and product
and distribution and kind of you know
building a business there
uh and then you were also writing on the
blog
what was that process like so before you
ever think about doing a book was it
something where the writing made you
better at your day job your day job kind
of gave you content
for writing like talk a little bit just
how those two things kind of related to
each other
definitely yeah i think evergreen was
kind of my self-administered
mba you know like i looked at um
what was happening around me in the
valley i was living in san francisco and
watching all these companies kind of
take off and
just realizing like how much i did not
know um and what i needed to know in
order to kind of do my job better and
build this company
and so i started kind of picking um the
way evergreen worked
i would pick one topic so i'd say like
all right this week is network effects
and i'd send out to my mailing list like
please give me the best thing you've
ever read
watch listen to whatever about network
effects
so i'd get thousands of responses um
over time i had thousands of responses
and as a mailing list built up at first
it was just like a trickle trickle
jiggle but
the things that you get at the most of
um you read and you dive into
it's kind of this crowd-sourced amazing
material and so i would read all of that
in a week listen to it
synthesize it do my best to write kind
of
a like 10 to 15-minute synthesis of like
here's the big ideas
uh here's the things that conflict that
i couldn't quite figure out even
and then links back to the original
material and then share that with
everybody who contributed and
the rest of the mailing list and so it
was just kind of my process for learning
in public
and absolutely that made me better at my
day job
you know i could not possibly have
learned as quickly
just kind of like going around running
into walls as i could asking all these
brilliant people
like all over the world like what how
they learn about these things and what
the best resources they are
and so as i just like pounded this into
my head and had a deadline
and an audience that was counting on me
to publish something um it really kind
of
increased the bar that i held myself to
for what i was learning
um i was just writing book reports on
you know business concepts and how to
build teams and how to build
growth strategies and you know
fundamentals of business you know
value creation and value capture are
still some of the most popular posts
and one of the things that's interesting
for what you end up doing with the book
is you basically were taking in
immense amounts of information you were
synthesizing it into very kind of
uh readable uh highly um
like with high comprehension right of
like how do i take all this information
boil it down to the most important parts
and then present it in a way that
people can um take away you know actions
and lessons
things like that uh was that an acquired
skill and just kind of trial by fire
did you you know somehow were born with
that like like
talk through a little bit of just that's
not something that a lot of people can
do very well
i i think it's um it's interesting you
said because i think we're kind of all
doing that to some extent now right like
we're all drinking from the fire hose
every day we're following you know
hundreds or thousands of people we got
new content like jammed in our face all
the time and so there's like ability to
curate
and figure out what to pay attention to
and what not to something we're all
having to learn like really quickly
um it's interesting i kind of like fell
backwards into this theme of curation
you know i'm a little bit of like a
digital hoarder
um and so you know my pocket is like if
it could overflow it'd be overflowing
it's it's
enormous it takes two minutes to load
and every time i pull it up like
um there's there's a lot and i love just
kind of like
gathering it and swimming around in it
categorizing things
and kind of seeing how it all connects
to each other you know
building those mental models building
that map of what's out there and how
things
have worked and stories of what worked
in the past and
so we are all kind of curating to an
extent um
but i found when i had to curate and
publish that was a great learning
process for me you know like this all
starts with
how can i get better how can i improve
how can i learn um
how can i up my skill set and like
become you know better at my job better
at writing and so this is
part of my my process and having an
audience and a product that you're
trying to work towards
as a final piece that you have to
publish and put your name on like
really you know it's skin in the game
like it makes you kind of
up your game and work harder at it and
put in more reps and
um it's funny to see the theme kind of
evolve now and i'm like i guess
just curation from an enormous like pile
of digital stuff is like
becoming my thing you know like that was
the theme of evergreen that's kind of
what happened
you know with the navalmenac as well you
know this thing started with
almost 100 sources and well over a
million words i've been following neval
for 10 years i've learned so much from
him
he he was kind of the first person in
the valley who i got
directed to that was like following all
go read all of angel hacks
you know uh venture hacks sorry um pre
pre-angel list
and um you know that'll kind of
inculcate you to the culture and like
show you what's going on out there
okay awesome and then you know as as he
kind of continued to
grow and evolve and share different
stuff i was learning new things and
um you know talks that he gave it at
pando daily back in the day and now
podcast interviews and stuff i'd learned
so much
but it was all kind of slowly over time
and i found myself kind of recommending
his resources to people more and more
and you know i think
nabal would say this about that or this
is a problem that have all had talked
about before
and that just i realized how difficult
it was to share
kind of some of his insights with people
because it was it was all
in a podcast or it was all in twitter
and if they weren't a twitter person or
a podcast person like
that was just gone to them and those are
very both very kind of ephemeral mediums
like after a year
or even last on twitter it's just it's
just gone if you don't know exactly what
to search for if you don't know it's
there if you didn't pull it into your
personal notes or whatever
like that's just lost to the world um
and this kind of
knowledge was so um it was life-changing
for me
that you know has been changing
life-changing for others that i thought
you know we should get this into a more
evergreen kind of
medium that's going to be easier to hand
off it's going to be easier on-ramp for
people who
are new to these ideas so
obviously naval had a huge impact on you
just as he has you know many many people
and i think
part of the attraction uh for people to
him
is it's not just business advice right
it's kind of this idea of there's
business advice there's life advice
there's
kind of self evaluation advice there's
happiness like there's all these
elements to it
at some point you decide that you're
going to uh take all this information
you're going to synthesize it and
distill it down and you're going to
write a book
the book is titled the almanac of naval
ravicon
a guide to wealth and happiness uh is
navalmanak is that a official title
as well or is that a uh easy easier to
remember for people
that's that's my that's my nickname for
it you can't go around saying almanac of
naval rav account all day every day
that's just
it's too much it's a long domain you
know so uh
so i just kind of shorthand it to
navalmanak and you know people either
get it or they don't but
i'm cool with that i love that
um all right so let's talk just about uh
at what point do you actually decide hey
i'm going to write a book
uh was it actually the original idea to
do a book um
and then kind of let's go through your
process uh because you took a lot of
information and got it down to uh
to something that's pretty compelling
yeah for sure so i started
um started kind of in a whirlwind it was
you know i thought of a pun one night
this the original title for this book
was the book of novalidge
um and i i had this tiny little like
um it was right after uh neval did the
interview with shane parish on the
knowledge project it was
amazing and it's been downloaded
millions of times it's an incredible
interview
um and there was so much in that that
was kind of like then it just really
struck me in the face it was like this
is so
good this is all kind of timeless book
worthy wisdom
um that i want more people to kind of
make it easier for them to receive
so i tweeted out uh if i made the book
of novalidge compiling some transcripts
and some tweets
like would you guys be into that you
know and i i didn't have a huge
following this was probably you know
10 000 people or whatever and i you know
this is 10 o'clock at night i tweeted
that out went to bed i woke up and naval
had retweeted it and 5 000 people reply
to this poll and we're like
hell yeah we want that like here we go
um and so it was kind of instant like
public commitment instant validation
instant
um oh my god i have to do this and
there's no way out like i know i'm
letting down
naval and he was kind of very generous
to say immediately like happy to provide
you with anything you want
you know do you need an archive of
tweets what do you what do you need to
make this a great project
and i don't know um what made him
trust a stranger from the internet to
say like yeah go ahead and write a book
about me
based on the stuff that's already out
there um
but it was uh it felt like a
great project to take on i was really
excited to kind of do this and
immediately people started kind of
checking in on the project and dming me
and saying like
hey when's this gonna be ready when's
this gonna be ready um three months in i
had like collected this huge pile of
stuff
i had you know this back catalog of his
tweets just 20 000 tweets and a giant
spreadsheet
and you know just building this list of
sources that's going and going and going
and the more you find
the more you're like oh my god there's
so much gold here especially kind of the
deeper you go back
and then you start categorizing things
and so i would build kind of um
i went through the tweets first and it
was really interesting to see
10 years of twitter history because how
people use twitter has changed so much
and you can see like
almost layers of sediment right that
never was starting venture hacks and
angelus there's a lot of
startup um kind of investing content and
here's how to use it and iterating
through content and early product
and then kind of building hype around it
and then it was a little bit more about
how to operate a startup who's building
a team he's hiring um
and there was more about investing and
as angelus became more and more
successful and kind of independent you
see him kind of shift towards
how to live a good life like about
philosophy
share more of the principles around what
he did to build angel lists
um it's really you see this you know
pattern in a lot of biographies and
things that you read
of people who kind of change their focus
overlapping even you know farnam street
started out very very like
business investing focused and kind of
transitioned you know
more into this is how you live a good
life this is how you build strong
relationships this is how you
you know find peace um and it's i think
a journey that we are all kind of on and
one of the things i like about
this final product of this book is that
there is something for absolutely
everyone no matter where they kind of
are in that journey
you know 21 year old might be like
really hungry and just hit that help
with that wealth section
you know like over and over and over and
over again um
but somebody who's kind of later in
their life might find one or two
principles from
the wealth section that they want to
apply but really you know
use the happiness section as a
touchstone to kind of
um keep themselves reminded of more of
that because that's where their focus is
to be more present to be with their
family something like that
so this book took you a pretty long time
to write
uh and mainly it was it sounds like a
lot of uh going through all the material
that was there right it was almost like
it was there you had to find the stuff
and
categorize it uh how much of this book
is
uh things that were already out there
versus um you know
either interviews with naval or
elsewhere and i'm cheating because i
know the answer
but uh kind of talk through you know
your reliance on the ball or people
close to the wall versus just stuff out
that was available in public domain
yeah that's um a thing that i struggled
with actually because novel was was
willing to contribute interviews and
things like that um
but one of the constraints i put on
myself was this has to be
entirely built from publicly available
material like i wanted that to be a
piece of the book
um that anyone could have done this or
could have found all of these i think it
like kind of makes it a very interesting
thing i tried to do
i did no editorializing like there's not
an original word from me
in this book past the author's note like
i wrote the author's note every other
word
as close as i could possibly get it
edited for readability
is is from naval in his own words um
and it was it was really a lot more like
doing a
jigsaw puzzle than it was writing you
know there's
there's so many times i wish i could
just edit this sentence i wish i could
just clarify like i wanted i want to
write here i wanted to change the words
um but you can't alter the piece you
just have to find the right place for it
and uh we were kind of figuring out what
the
right exact thread is like all of the
right pieces are here you can build an
amazing kind of reading experience
and and so much of this comes from
interviews uh the body of the text comes
from interviews for the most part
that it feels very kind of narrative
one-to-one it's almost like a dialogue
you know it's
it's almost feels kind of like the
courage to be disliked or
um you know some of those other kind of
dialogue books that like pull you
through it's very casually written
um it's not super structured but i
wanted to give enough categorization so
that you could really easily
reference it go back for specific ideas
you know check in on things
um and use it kind of over and over
again because
you can really power through it in a
first read but
but also like once those seeds are
planted you're going to want to keep
coming back and get
refreshed on the ideas and reapply them
so
uh this past weekend uh i now they
ordered the hardcover book which
everyone should go do and we'll get to
that in a second uh
but also i downloaded the pdf and i
started reading i was telling you that
uh i probably i don't know 80 85 of the
way through and i basically did it in
almost one sitting
uh and what's crazy is i've pretty much
heard almost all the interviews i've
seen the tweets like
you know there's plenty of stuff in
there that i hadn't seen before but for
the most part
uh you know the general things or the
meat of it
i had already consumed and it still was
incredibly valuable and i think that's
like a very
interesting uh component maybe talk a
little bit about
kind of how you thought about using the
public information right so there's
plenty of people obviously when the
vault is a podcast or those tweets
uh that have already consumed this stuff
yet there's still some value here and
kind of writing it down the way you did
and to talk
about how you thought of like the value
for the reader and what they'll get out
of this one
when they consume the book yeah i think
it's a totally different experience to
kind of consume
a series of podcasts than it is to go
really deep on one specific topic you
know this was kind of
um this is the thesis of evergreen two
right like you can read one article a
week about network effects
and one article a week about value
capture but unless you
are actually like intensely studying one
topic and mapping things to each other
and kind of
put it all on the table in front of you
it's really hard to see the big picture
and see
how all the concepts relate so you know
you've seen tweets about from naval
about
finding leverage or about how to use
leverage
but until you read you know 10 pages
about leverage this is every example
that he's ever used
that is every specific kind of tool of
leverage
or every uh you know it starts with the
categorization and it goes into
how to actually apply it and then it
goes into kind of examples like the real
estate industry or
contractors about how to apply leverage
to your own business
that you really start to kind of fully
kind of picture the idea
and figure out how you start seeing that
pattern now in real life so it's
you know the definement idea of like
learning the name of something versus
really like learning the system of it
my goal here was to provide so much
context on the key ideas
and so much depth and so much clarity
that we really kind of
showed people the whole system showed
people the whole concept in a way that
really stuck with you much more than
being like oh yeah leverage is important
i get it
um and i kind of know what leverage is
but but you're still not unless you're
seeing it in everyday life and
understanding
how people are building businesses with
leverage or with accountability or with
specific knowledge
then you don't really own that idea and
it's not really going to change
you know your life or your trajectory
enough so
getting that really high bar of
understanding is important to me and i
think
is what kind of separates this from some
of the more casual kind of like
dabbling in these ideas it's really easy
to do on social media or podcast
talk a little bit about um some of your
favorite parts of the book right and so
ultimately this is kind of the
best of the best content from the ball
what sticks out in your mind if somebody
was to say you know name your two or
three most favorite things
um after having spent so much time and
really kind of obsessing over
every word that he's ever said yeah i
think um leverage and accountability are
my two
on the wealth side i think um to kind of
briefly summarize them like
accountability
is just a more precise uh and
fair kind of phrasing of the old folk
wisdom like it
takes money to make or it takes wealth
uh takes risk to make money like you
have to kind of
put yourself out there entrepreneurs
take on risk and what entrepreneurs
actually do is take accountability for
the risk that exists
you know they are willing to put
themselves out there you publish this
podcast
and your newsletters and everything
under your own name like that's
accountability
you have to be willing to take on the
downside if you you know take on the
debt to start a new business like
you are personally taking accountability
for that it doesn't mean you have to
take risk it doesn't mean you have to
actually like find the riskiest thing
that you can do you know the advice you
go take
risk is actually like quite dangerous
the advice
that you are accountable for the risk
that you take and you have to very
carefully
manage that risk like that idea is kind
of baked into accountability
which is a like a piece of nuance that i
thought was really really helpful
to kind of complement the folk wisdom of
entrepreneurship that's out there
on the leverage side of things that he
really classified it as
capital labor and products with no
marginal cost of replication
um which is an asterisk but a little bit
of a mouthful
but that's software that's
podcasts media you know these things are
all relatively new and we're still
seeing how much they kind of change the
economics of some of these businesses
it doesn't cost anyone well maybe
youtube but you know
more for to serve it to 100 million
people than it does to 100 and so if you
create a great video
the meritocracy of the internet will
take over and you can have incredibly
outsized returns by using
this kind of productized leverage that's
out there so
um those are two on the well side on the
happiness side you know there's a lot
of kind of little habits in there and
and things that he
recommends and um pieces of uh
philosophy that he pulls in
but really that all starts with
realizing that
we're going to be here a very short time
in the scheme of things like
life is short the universe has been here
a long time it'll be here a long time
um and realizing that any moment that
you are not
choosing to be happy and choosing to
interpret the inputs of the world in a
positive
way you're not doing anyone any favors
like
you're not making you're not making
yourself better off you're not making
the people around you better off and you
are in control of that like you can
choose to be happy you can choose
positive interpretations
and when you do everyone around you and
you are better off for it
but no one can choose that for you you
have to choose it for yourself
um and so it is a you have to kind of
zoom all the way out to get back to this
tiny little
choice and this tiny little thing that
we all have but it's kind of a
core core piece and just reminding
yourself of that as
often as you possibly can can be a
really transformative thing for your for
your mindset and your mood
and and everything just kind of comes
easier when you remember that like it
doesn't have to be hard it doesn't have
to be miserable
you're not you're not more productive
because you're unhappy like
just choose a positive take on all of
this and like keep going
were there any surprises for you in
terms of uh putting this together
um either from the content or the
process
yeah there were definitely some um i
mean there were a lot of unknowns when i
started this project right
it came up so fast um kind of out of
nowhere
that at first my first idea was like hey
i put together like a little tiny ebook
you know
a little thing there's you know 20 pages
and then when i had all this material in
front of me i was like oh my god this is
this is huge i'm going to make it you
know 600 page version of it i'm going to
cover every category this is going to be
port charlie's almanac
maybe i should just build like a tool
that actually allows for live updating
and it's more of kind of like
a blogs thing that does it would be have
to be like a little transformed because
it's not about whatever's newest it's
about the best ideas and how you combine
them all
so there was a lot of kind of um
creative crossroads along the way
i wasn't sure if i should be writing
about naval's ideas or
or just kind of getting out of the way
and letting them speak for themselves
um so it was tough to kind of navigate
some of those things
and and find the right mix of
constraints that let me keep making
progress
um i'm really really happy with where we
ended up there's every chance that that
this could have become something totally
different um if someone had given me
kind of a different
push along the way trevor mckendree
actually writes like an awesome
newsletter
um i like brought him a mess of a
manuscript early on and i was like i
don't even know what this thing is
supposed to be
like is it gonna be a blog is it gonna
be a book like
how are we gonna get there from here and
he's like don't overthink it it's a book
just
get back to work um keep making it a
book
i was like okay that actually like
clears up a lot it just took the right
person to kind of like
slap me and and get me back on the road
and now all of a sudden i'm making
progress again
um the other the other kind of big
thing was just like how comprehensive
should it be you know there was my first
draft of this
manuscript was 600 pages it was
well over a hundred thousand words it
was huge um the final product for
reference is like
less than 50 000 which is like much more
of a normal book but this was
an encyclopedia for a minute of like
everything interesting that i thought
naval had ever said
um which included you know sections on
blockchain and education
and investing and building startups
because all like
this is such a fun project for me
because i'm interested in all of the
stuff that nimble has said
um i think there's there's thought
experiments
and you know futurism and there's so
much stuff in there that i thought was
was important and interesting and
helpful um and it took
a really kind of broad wide range of
peer reviewers
kind of after that manuscript who i gave
them a 600 page thing and they're like
you'll be [ __ ] kidding me
um and they all read like a different 60
percent
um but the all all of them loved wealth
and happiness
and so that was kind of a go figure
right like everybody wants to be
wealthy and happy so those became like
the foundation of it and figuring out
what to put around that to give it the
right context
make it like a fast engaging kind of
awesome read i really want people to
power through the end of the book and be
like oh my god i wish this was longer
like that's the best compliment a book
can receive
and all those sections are now kind of
published on
on thebalmenac.com so there's no reason
not to have them on the website and put
them out there for people who are
interested in it
but i really wanted them to power
through the book and then find their way
to kind of
different rabbit holes based on what
they were interested in
but that that early kind of feedback on
the first first manuscript was
so key to get me through some of the
some of the things that
um was hard to see past what i was
interested in and and learn
kind of what other people would want to
see in it yeah
it feels like you've had this um very
intimate experience where you're like
spending all day with
uh the thoughts of somebody uh and
obviously it being the ball is
um is cool and valuable but how do you
think
you've changed just from spending that
much time kind of rereading
so much of this kind of high quality
content uh and i've got to imagine
almost like searing it in your brain to
the point where like
you can literally call it back like a
database right of just like hey i know
exactly what
the thoughts are on this topic or that
topic like how have you changed
or maybe just your perspective changed
yeah it's
it's actually um i think you know when
you've changed when it's hard to
pinpoint how you've changed
you know um i definitely i mean i read
this book and
some of the source material like more
than 20 times in the course of building
this thing over
three years like there's hundreds and
hundreds of hours into this
um of just sitting with this material
and picking up a piece and trying to
kind of totally
figure out totally understand it and
figure out what else it relates to
um so i almost feel guilty at like how
many things i'm sure i adopted as my own
in this process that i'm like
this is now my idea but it definitely
came from from this process in this book
um but i think you know we are we are
all doing that we are all standing on
many layers of
shoulders of giants um so it has been
kind of part of that process but the
the this kind of crucible of editing
that i've been going through
the reward for that is that i now have
like a little
like naval who sits on my shoulder like
he is on my mental board of directors i
have like a hogwarts portrait in my head
that to such an extent that like i can
almost ask it questions
and know what it it would say back um
and that is a really high bar you know
you you don't have time to do that with
very many people
in in your life um to study an idea that
deeply or a person that deeply
and i'm very kind of grateful that
you know it was a very kind of a
luck-based thing that like this became
the book that i was working on
like i tweet dumb stuff all the time
this one just happened to turn into a
book
and i'm i'm very lucky that like this
agreed with
so much of what i wanted to know and
what i wanted to learn like i'm
um it would have been hard to sit with
three years of just anybody so like
picking who to study and who to kind of
whose ideas to let this deeply into your
head i think is
is important and i'm really glad that um
that we're over that
threshold and that like this is the bar
that i reached in working on this book
and you know for me personally it was it
was transformative to a point where like
i don't i would love everyone in the
world to read it and get something out
of it but i don't need that to feel good
about having spent this time
working on it like this was this is a
project for me from the beginning
and i hope everyone gets something out
of it and i think many people love
it but i'm also would not be
disappointed in the time invested if all
it did was change me
um and teach me things so
that leads me to one of the more
interesting decisions that you made
is uh everything is available for free
unless you want a hardcover version
um and so this is my my plug for you and
that everyone listening should
uh go read it for free on the internet
but also buy a hardcover version like i
did
uh simply just as a thank you i think
really to spend so much time to put it
together
uh but talk a little bit about the
decision to uh actually kind of open
source or provide
uh without cost um you know have all
this work that you've done over a number
of years
and what drove that yeah that's um i
wish i could take full credit for that
that was actually an important
kind of piece that naval wanted in the
book um
that i was very very happy to about you
know all of my writing
forever has been free um you know
evergreen was totally free and all my
blog posts are out there and stuff
so um that totally agreed with my ethos
um
i didn't understand exactly
all of the reasons why that was so
important until actually this week so
publishing this week and getting
hundreds of tweets and dms and emails
from people all over the world who
don't have access to amazon or to the
kindle store or whatever
like i didn't even realize
how difficult it was for them to get
their hands on some of these things like
pay pay like a side um
but to pay you know us dollars for a
book of ideas that could change
somebody's life in you know the
philippines
like that's a higher bar for them um not
everyone has
you know amazon service or a kindle or a
device to download a kindle on
but so putting it out there as a pdf and
free on the website like there are
people who are
very very grateful for that um and it's
kind of a transformative thing um i
think it is also
you know i mean it's been downloaded
tens of thousands of times already
um so it is clear that it adds value to
people
i think enough people are gonna kind of
share this and appreciate it
and and there's a lot more to kind of do
around these ideas um
but but really naval has given all of
this you know these lessons away
i'm very happy to kind of add my um
curatorial efforts to it and and pay
that forward
you know the best i can and um plenty of
people are going to
want to buy the book or um we made it as
cheap as we can on amazon
in the kindle store but amazon does not
want to do free hosting and distribution
it turns out so um they set
they set price floors but everything um
we made it available for free on the
website novalmac.com
you can read the whole thing you can
download epub moby pdf put it in your
kindle
print it out whatever you want to do
like it's all out there
got it uh are you gonna write another
one
maybe who do you wanna who do you wanna
see the almanac of next
oh i i'd have to think hard uh if you're
gonna go spend three years of your life
it would have to be somebody that meets
that same quality
bar i'm not gonna just throw a random
name out there and then you go
uh go do it if you if you think of it
you you send it you send it to me um
i'm not gonna rule it out but i'm also
not gonna just go
you know kind of crank them out to crank
them out um
there's there's actually i think a lot
to do around
around this book for for application and
tools and
services and things like that like this
book i think is just the beginning of
the journey for many people on
figuring out how to find their specific
knowledge right like
it takes many many years and not
everybody has the kind of advantages of
people around them who can
help them distill it or kind of make
prescriptive recommendations on on what
they should be doing or make you know
even have healthy relationships business
relationships with them to kind of
coach them through some of these things
um you know there's definitely a lot to
learn about the tools of leverage
and you know how many ways there are to
kind of
buy back your own time and work on high
leverage tasks and things like that like
this is something i think
you have done incredibly well but you
know with no playbook
that i can see just kind of like
intuiting your way forward
to figure out like what you are uniquely
really good at
how to find kind of tools that help you
get you know more reach and find more
audience and serve
the people who follow you better um so
that that is something that i think
you know there's a lot to kind of do and
unpack there and and
you know i don't know that i'm done with
um with these ideas just yet
one of the things that's really
interesting me and i you'll know i won't
uh
where where he said it but i think it
was in like the how to be rich
um kind of series of of audio clips
um basically this idea of leverage right
to me
is uh we know that compounding uh kind
of was misunderstood
to those now who uh look at building
wealth that's kind of you know now a uh
a discovered truth if you will
right and everyone kind of talks about
it um leverage
seems to be kind of in that phase that
compounding used to be
right where uh there's certainly people
who understand it but
kind of the general mass audience
doesn't understand
with any level of mastery or really kind
of
application why that's so important
right
and so do you think that this is
something where uh
simply hearing the ideas right kind of
the way he articulates it is enough for
people
or do you think that there is this
element of like this is almost the top
of the funnel
right where you got to kind of hear an
idea hear somebody explain it now that
you
you know trust and have legitimacy and
kind of all that stuff
and then they've got to kind of walk
through it but you actually don't
um kind of internalize it until you
actually put it into application
so kind of how do you separate ideas
versus action here and kind of where do
you think this book fits
yeah i mean i think i'm i'm always a
proponent of the like
you don't actually understand it until
you've you've tested it against reality
until you've like heard the echo of what
you've put out there
and and see it work and see it in action
um
i totally agree like leverage is really
i think pretty
tangled up with compounding in some ways
like the gap between
you know you doing your most high value
tasks is is another
thing that compounds you know getting
getting leverage through capital giving
getting leverage through labor this is
why you see
you know the business owners pretty
consistently become
the wealthiest people because they are
leveraged and they're leveraged
through capital through labor and
through products and
all of these things kind of the leverage
itself compounds
um and gets bigger and bigger and all
you know the capitals compounding the
labor is compounding and that the
profits are coming back and getting
reinvested
and so i think there's a lot to kind of
um continue to unpack there i think
you know to your point like people
definitely
everyone parrots compounding and
everyone understands that it's important
but it is still so counterintuitive and
so difficult for us
to you know even people who spent their
whole lives with
with compounding and studying it still
have to go look at the tables and be
like oh holy [ __ ] that is so much more
than i thought it would
like the mental math is still
counterintuitive
and still surprisingly high um i think
leverage is
is i completely agree with you that it
is kind of like
in the same lane but lagging
the understanding of compounding and
it's just less a little less
um studied and understood and a little
less like
uh mathematically quantified yet in the
way that um
compounding is productized leveraged
probably in particular um
and people are seeing like you know
break out successes like joe rogan or or
um this kind of phenomenon of companies
getting smaller
or uh head count getting smaller and
companies getting bigger and so
you know instagram at a billion with 10
people and whatsapp
and you know bitcoin even like these
things are that that is all productized
leverage that people are still
not quite seeing as like the support
beam that it is for the outcomes that
we're seeing
i think it's absolutely huge i think
it's a really interesting
thing to kind of continue to study and
naval's
um broad classification of it as
leverage and
just labeling it leverage really helps
us kind of
think about it you know we think of
labor as so different from capital and
so
different from product until it's all
under the same umbrella you kind of oh
holy [ __ ] how can i like
mix and match these two is this a
problem that needs to be solved with
labor is it a problem that can be solved
with capital is it a problem that can be
solved with product how do i mix these
together
um which actually is the most expensive
or the most
the highest margin form of leverage for
this particular challenge that i'm
taking on like
there's a lot to explore there um and
i'm actually like
it's one of the concepts that i'm most
excited to kind of keep diving into and
kind of do my own
research on and keep writing on
hopefully and
see where that takes me to me one of the
aspects as you're reading through it and
kind of
really really like looking at the words
on a page right not just hearing a
podcast etc
it's very obvious that uh his command of
these ideas
is due to his um
application of them right and so it's
like the idea of leverage like even the
way that he describes the various types
of leverages
he specifically highlights not just
software right not just human capital he
also talks about
blogs and podcasts and like like he
really really understands that when you
kind of take a step back like
because he's done all of it right and so
did you get the sense that
um he has this ability to articulate
these ideas
because of his specific experience or do
you think that this is something where
anyone who sat and just thought about
this stuff for a long time could kind of
come to the same conclusions and
have the same command of the
descriptions
in these ideas yeah i think it i think
it takes some
experience with reality some operating
experience to kind of get
um not just fluent with these concepts
but
to have them distilled so powerfully you
know um it is a very
non-academic thing right it's not a guy
who's
studied a bunch of different things and
wrote a big paper with a bunch of
confusing words
about you know how leverage applies it
is like a man who has built and invested
in
you know he's built a few successful
businesses he's invested in hundreds of
successful businesses
and he has this kind of like mental
model of
how these things come about and what
he's looking for
and that is just you know and in a few
kind of simple words can explain that
and now he's been studying these things
he says he formulated some of these
things when he was 14
and just like you know a poor immigrant
kid in new york
looking around trying to figure out how
the world works and how people get money
and how to become successful
so he's been distilling these principles
for decades and
applying them and learning them and so
um you know
even there's a blog post from 2008 that
is like
surprised me with how far back it was
there was some of these kind of basic
equations you know
your income equals your specific
knowledge plus accountability plus
leverage
very basic formula doesn't mean anything
to you until you've read the other until
you can unpack all those words into the
things that he's been thinking about for
10 years
which is kind of what this book does but
it really surprised me how
how long he's been thinking about it and
it shows you like
you know this clarity comes from years
of distillation
and practice and application and and
receiving kind of
um feedback from the universe that these
theories are
correct and once they're in your head
you're looking around at other people
seeing how you know you see this formula
everywhere and you start to see how
how people take accountability how they
use specific knowledge how they use
leverage
and it almost becomes a formula for kind
of um understanding
how they became successful or how they
continue to grow and
and that's really where you start to see
how you can apply it for yourself
you know that that's where you get to
the 301 401 like oh i i see the world
differently now and now i understand if
i push this button this thing can happen
now i understand if i start this
business it can become profitable with
the use of these tools these these
pieces of leverage
instead of just you know trying to do
everything manually
um and you understand the difference
between you know
the level of accountability that an
hourly worker has versus
their manager versus the owner of the
business like these are things that not
everyone
is is lucky enough to ever see how the
world works and how
why some people are successful and why
um others are getting wealthy and
and some aren't that is um i find that
to be a very valuable
thing to just understand the truths of
some of these things and
um see the forces that are at work
yeah it's it's really really interesting
to kind of hear you
navigate that balance between just
thinking
and doing um what what happens next will
you continue to update this
and kind of on an annual or every few
year basis
uh i'm assuming that uh naval is not
going to stop
doing or thinking uh nor putting more
information out there like how do you
think about
uh kind of the evolution of his thoughts
in regards to the book
yeah it depends um i think it depends a
little bit on
many things but what he does what he
shares um i worked
very hard to ensure that everything in
the book is is evergreen um
so i hope that the book itself will
never go out of date or become
applicable um naval i'm sure we'll
continue to share many
great insights and and new things um if
we needed an updated version in you know
10 years or something like we can we
could talk about that
i definitely continue to will continue
to kind of update the site and
and write more there um i've got a
mailing list when it all comes out with
great new stuff i'll share it
um i may continue to kind of try to
expand on some of these ideas on the
blog
share more about how the book came about
and what is happening as a result of the
book
um you know some of the stuff we talked
about around
how to help people you know go further
with these ideas how to get more
you know in tune with their specific
knowledge how to apply leverage um
might be something that we we do um i
don't know
the whole last section of the book is
recommended reading
uh so there's all these kind of great
books across philosophy
and you know non-fiction you know
there's a bunch of matt ridley
and talib and one of the things um that
i've heard is that a reading group
might be really interesting for people
who want to kind of get together
and study naval's recommendations and
his ideas and create a
you know kind of a little like naval
university if you want to swim deeper
into these ideas let's go into the
source material together let's really
you know ask each other some of the hard
questions hold each other accountable
for for doing the hard work of studying
some of these kind of
basic you know source texts you know
it's
not easy work to read the origin of
species or um
you know go all the way back to some of
the early philosophers but
if that's you know what you want to hold
yourself to like it's easier to do that
as part of a group
yeah makes uh makes a lot of sense um if
anyone wants to
buy the book the almanac of naval
ravikant a guide to
wealth and happiness uh they can go to
navalmanac
dot com uh is the best place to buy the
uh the hardcover and then
you can also download the uh the pdf uh
or other versions for uh for free there
uh before i let you go ask everyone the
same two questions then you'll get to
ask me one
uh first is what is your favorite book
or most important book you've ever read
and you cannot answer
uh with this one so you have to choose
something else but uh what's the most
important book you've ever read
uh poor charlie's almanac for sure um i
picked that up off my dad's bookshelf at
like
21 and it totally changed the next five
or ten years of what i read and what i
thought
um absolutely loved it and i actually
think it's interesting like looking back
at how that decision contributed to the
decision to like
create this book like it was in you know
the the curation and
distillation was in me from how much i
appreciated poor charlie's almanac
um so i absolutely love that book i love
um
and i hope that uh you know i've done
the almanac tradition proud with this
how much of the impact that book had on
you is the content in the book versus
when you read it because i actually
uh same for me like when i was 20 21
years old i read
uh three books um and i always go back
and forth like
was it the content or was it just i was
20 21 years old and like
perfect age to mold my my opinions and
view points on the world
yeah i mean i think every every book
that you stack on you know
that might have been ten percent or one
percent of the books you've read but by
now when you read a new one it's like a
fraction of a percent of the books that
you've read and so
you know you're just you just swing so
much more with any new big influence on
your life at that age
um i definitely and i also you know
deeply respected my dad and knew that he
loved
monger and you know we warren buffett
had been a topic of conversation in our
house for some time
so um i had a reason to kind of buy into
that already but it was definitely a mix
of
you know um he monger fit my my
personality and world view and
irreverence you know uh
kind of bang bang like alignment
perfectly
um so i loved him just kind of is
curmudgeonly
intelligence um and just dismissive of
experts and
um just all of those idiosyncratics
idiosyncrasies um i loved and
uh it was it was hugely impactful for me
and then i went into you know
benjamin franklin and all the stuff that
he recommends and
um yeah he's still still a huge
influence on me
that's awesome uh second question a
little bit more fun which is uh
aliens believer or non-believer believer
why the universe is a huge place
and i know it's like so staggeringly big
that you can't actually do the math but
if you could it just seems
extremely unlikely that somewhere in
infinity
there's not other other beings
so uh i never realized i've asked a lot
of people almost 400 people this
question
uh and i always ask it the exact way i
just did and somebody over the weekend
told me they're like
you can't ask a question that relies on
math and
categorize it as believer or
non-believer
like math is either true or not and i
was like that's a that's pretty good
point
so i think i might have to call the new
phrasing for it because your point
like the math equation is what most
people rely on uh
but i don't know if we can really call
do we believe math that's basically the
question right well maybe the people
that
yeah not everyone might agree that it's
a math i don't know who that would be
but in this audience it's probably a
pretty
pretty math heavy bigfoot believer or
non-believer
yeah i don't know maybe that's
understandable it's bigfoot the loch
ness monster i'm sure there's a couple
others that we can come up with
uh all right you could ask me one
question to finish up what uh what one
question you got for me
i wanna know uh what you would consider
your specific knowledge
yeah so um you know this but for those
that are listening
uh specific knowledge can be kind of
captured a couple different ways and one
that i think a lot about is like when
you stack three or four things on top of
each other
uh so you know an easy example would be
if you understand
business if you understand finance if
you understand content and you
understand
investing like there's just not that
many people you're competing against
at the intersection of those four things
right and so i constantly think about
like
well what else can you add like how do
you go from four things to like 10
things right
um and in some weird world
uh i actually think the specific
knowledge is more like intangible things
for me
so what i mean by that is like one uh
there's not very many people who are
willing to kind of be
curious publicly right so this idea of
like there's a lot of people who i think
are very guarded and
they only want to uh put things out
there when they feel like this is the
finished product and like i look my best
whereas for me like you know people come
on all the time on the podcast
especially and they'll
tell me things that i'm like completely
wrong on my thoughts before they came on
so i think that's one piece related to
that is this idea that
uh i pretty regularly don't care what
other people think i mean you know i'm
human and like
i've got an ego and like all that kind
of stuff so there's definitely some
people that it's important
uh but when it comes to uh most people i
don't really
care and so by not caring uh it allows
me to be i think a little bit more
honest in that like intellectual
exploration
um and then the other piece that i think
is really hard for people to layer
into you know business and finance and
content and all that kind of stuff
uh is the psych psychology aspect so
in college you know if college was
helpful
type argument like i said economics and
sociology which are like two things that
are related but not very popular in
terms of somebody getting a degree
and if you think about content in
general it's just psychology
right and so when you start to think of
everything i do
through like just understanding people
and how they react to things
uh it becomes much clearer like okay
that's why it's working
at the same time like i think that's
pretty hard to replicate because it kind
of falls in the cree
creative bucket right of like you could
teach a machine to do a lot of things
but like can you teach a machine how to
react
to people and how they change and i
don't know maybe
right there's there's somebody smart out
there who can do it uh i haven't seen
too many of them yet and so like
that's generally how i think about it
but at the same time like that's a
pretty shitty answer and like not very
concrete so it's like i'm still figuring
it out
right no i think that's i think that's
huge i think the you know
not caring whether what other people
think having fun with the stuff that
you're interested
in like that is um
it is a very intangible but actually
much more rare than people think
you know yeah and it's funny because
uh i joke all the time that
i'm only like this because i grew up in
a family of five boys and like we were
like
ruthless to each i mean you know you can
imagine
anything that anyone had dirt on the
other one like it was coming out at the
worst time
right and so like eventually you just
get this like really thick skin
um but having thick skin i think is a
little bit different than just like i
don't care what people think
and so at some point uh i do think that
some of naval's ideas around just like
if you're genuinely happy like
internally you're happy
and you're enjoying your life it makes
it much easier not to care what anybody
else thinks
right and so like i always think back
and like i've never thought about it
i've never been like am i a happy person
you know or anything like that
but um i don't know it's just
it's an interesting way to view the
world of like if you take care of
yourself everything else falls into
place
right and i think that's kind of his
message and obviously you did a great
job in the book of kind of like
hammering that home
and the way that you structured it and
so i think that like there's a lot of
truth there that people should go you
know explore
yeah i think that's you know um it's
funny how at least
in my life the whole my whole life has
been a process of finding out how wise
my parents were
slowly um and so you know one of my
mom's famous lines is like
who can you control and you've got to be
like me
and he's like you can't control anything
else you can control yourself
like and you're responsible for yourself
and at the end of the day
not for too much else you know um but
just just do your best for yourself and
and take care of your family and like
you're you're in good shape
i'll leave you with this because it's
right along these lines my father tells
people all the time whenever
you know that i see him you know couple
times a year or whatever if there's
anybody over there he goes oh yeah
my kids they're realizing i'm getting
smarter as i get older
like kind of like you know hey idiots
and nothing's changed i've been saying
the same thing for years right you guys
are just now rising up to it
yeah ultimate vindication long game the
parental long game
oh yeah yeah and trust me if the
internet had been around when we were
kids right there would be some
documentation of all the times where we
were like dad you don't know what you're
talking about right but uh
as uh as it happens for everybody they
tend to know what they're talking about
so yeah it's cool to kind of experience
that now
awesome eric uh where can people go find
the book or
find you on the internet yeah
navalmanex.com
has all the book stuff um it's got a ck
at the end that's the only weird part of
it uh i'm most active on twitter
at eric jorgensen um i got some random
writing on us on my site ejorgenson.com
um but dm email whatever i'm easy to get
a hold of
awesome man well listen from everybody
else just thank you for taking the time
to write this i know that it was uh
valuable to you but but i think that uh
there's a lot more people who are going
to uh
to benefit from it and uh it's the
ultimate leverage
so uh you are uh practicing what uh
what you were consuming there so thanks
so much for doing it i appreciate that
thanks a lot